[Music]
what's the deal with airplan peanuts
last weekend we attended the first
annual Sunshine Comedy Festival in Tampa
Florida to sit down for exclusive
interviews with dozens of comics and
recap the entire 4-day festival for our
subscribers right here on joke world but
unfortunately for our loyal subscribers
it was at this Festival that we made the
biggest mistake in the history of this
channel the sunshine Comedy Festival
started off great with over 50
world-class comedians making the voyage
to be part of this inaugural week
ranging from established Headliners like
Mark Norman and David Lucas to plenty of
Young and Hungry upand comers Uncle
laser what's the most white trash thing
you've done since arriving in Florida
this weekend I went to one of them strip
clubs up yonder and uh $100 cover to get
in damn but it was all you could drink
alcohol for free and they had a whirpool
Jacuzzi down there in the back you know
what I'm saying so me salt pepper
cinnamon and Nutmeg she was a guy she
was a guy we got in there and and I
didn't even get chyia right but I got
staff infection it had the it had the
consistency the water had consistency of
egg drop soup all right everything was
going swell to kick things off on
Thursday show started around 400 p.m.
and by 10:30 we were in our seats ready
to watch the Mark Norman and friend show
and grab our exclusive interview with
Mark afterwards at this point we'd
already interviewed a few comedians to
start the day such as cam Patterson and
rth Cruz so heading into our
conversation with Kevin Hart The Vibes
were Immaculate the show ended a little
4 1:00 a.m. and by 2:00 in the morning
we were sitting on stage with Chief
queef ready for our first in-person
interview with the joke machine this was
the third time we interviewed Mark and
honestly this conversation was one of
the best interviews we've ever done and
walking away from day one of the fest
with Mark Norman and camparison
interviews in our pocket felt amazing
especially because both these guys were
only in town for one night before
leaving to do other shows this High did
not last long at all however because the
next morning is when reality set in the
Mark Norman and cam Patterson interviews
that we only had one night to capture
looked great on film but one key detail
was missing the
audio there was there was no audio no
audio at all like like zero like it was
just no audio kind of like September
11th I'm still not exactly sure what
happened but I'll never forget the only
bright side to all of this I guess is
that we checked the audio Friday morning
so we avoided making this mistake the
rest of the weekend because if we would
have recorded all of these interviews
and walked away with literally no
content for this whole festival I would
have actually been forced to kill myself
but luckily we were able to quickly
learn this lesson the hardest way
possible and continue to interview
plenty of other great comedians asking
them all sorts of questions related to
The Comedy world as well as some more
specific questions related to the
sunshine Comedy Fest Jim there's over 50
comedians performing at this Festival in
your opinion who's the most underrated
person here Sean Gardini obviously by a
100 million miles and I think everybody
everyone who is actually cool knows that
in your opinion who's the most
underrated comic here [__] underrated I
have to look at the lineup who's
here I just name everyone that's I'm so
youed i' I've literally hold on stay
there Andy haes Andy Haynes
yeah Andy or I would say colum I think
colum Tyrell is is just is incredible so
I'd say Andy or colum at this Festival
in your opinion who's the most
underrated comic here underweight or
under
underrated who doesn't get enough praise
in the landscape of Comedy oh probably
Dean Stanfield most underrated uh that's
a tough question let me go Zack O Ryan
okay who's the most
overrated what if I was like oh dude
easy I mean I didn't even know that
there were 50 comedians that that were
asked that's a I didn't even know I was
on this Festival till like a week
ago oh you know he's not underrated but
he's blowing up cam Patterson is a
[__] fan favorite right now I would
just yeah he's everywhere he's amazing
not underrated but he should be on your
radar and we even found out that the
Mark Norman audio curse extended well
past just our janky operation we've had
three interviews no audio so far but
we're we're get my homie just filmed uh
Martin Norman at uh Tampa Theater
yesterday and he said the lapel just
recorded an hour of nothing are you
serious curse on him dude so he's
probably having a whole weekend and
people being like no audio had shotgun
mics so like the audio's still solid I
just I just watched the clip it's crazy
[__] up the audio with Mark and cam
not only hurt because they're arguably
the two biggest names on the entire
lineup but also just because they were
pretty good conversations that I'm
bummed you'll never get to hear
including cam Patterson's reaction to
finding out he won joke World newcoming
comedian of the year which seemed like a
legit special moment for him and his dad
who was standing off camera I also just
realized that might have been a spoiler
to anyone who hasn't watched the joke
World Awards Reveal video yet so check
that out right after this video if you
want to know who won all six of our fan
voted categories aside from cam
Patterson we also got to ask Mark Norman
about the Cat Williams podcast drama but
presented the question to ask him as if
he was actually Kevin Hart which is just
a perfect storm of inside jokes and
topical news all wrapped into one clip
that I just wish we could have posted so
[__] badly and to make matters even
worse the owner of Sid Splitters went
out of his way to let us film with Mark
in the main stage room so my deepest
apologies to Brian and to mark and to
cam and to all 400,000 subscribers this
is honestly so so embarrassing at this
point almost every major city has some
sort of Comedy scene that tries to
organize a festival of sorts in order to
Showcase their local talent give away
some awards and build up a regional
audience that will hopefully like what
they see and start coming out to more
live shows but what takes a Festival
located outside of one of the three
major comedy markets to the next level
of popularity and Longevity is the
ability to book top tier names outside
their local scene adding big names to
Festival lineups instantly helps with
all the marketing efforts and provides
an insane amount of credibility in the
eyes of fans which the sunshine Festival
did a great job of this lineup
definitely leaned heavy towards New York
comedians which in my opinion is a
Surefire way to have a great weekend of
standup guys like Mark Norman Mike
Cannon Troy Bond and colum Terrell all
murdered on stage along with some
big-time live podcasts like ban with
Jordan there were also plenty of killers
on this lineup from LA and Austin such
as Josh Wolf Jeff Dy Jeremiah Watkins
David Lucas cam Patterson and so so many
more including my personal MVP of the
Fest Ryan Joseph remember that name he's
going to be huge honestly I don't think
anyone had a bad set all weekend which
is not only a testament to those Comics
but also to the Bookers of this Fest and
the audience members who bought tickets
Florida was fun shout out to the
sunshine Comedy Festival oh you did that
was it was awesome start to finish um
listen did the weather cooperate no not
really but with even that it was so much
fun that's a [__] blast all the
crowds were awesome all the shows were
run smoothly you get to hang out with a
lot of comics you don't see a lot of
great like fun hang people in the same
place radiar was there right
andaran fance Catherine Blandford a good
crew Bianca she's from Austin I forget
her last name I think it starts with p
she's a good Hank Nicole Amy shriber
okay it was fun man Jordan Jensen
brought her dog I didn't get to meet her
dog Rose butd and Andy hannes were there
went to a comic brunch they brought
their kids Casey bosam let me hold her
baby for like almost 4 minutes that's
good despite its name this Festival was
not all sunshine and rainbows when it
comes to the downsides of this weekend
the two main qualms that stick out were
number one the weather which is
obviously out of anyone's control and
number two the distance between venues
over the course of the 4 days there were
moments when the sun came out but
overall it hovered around a misty 50°
which is fine for January but it would
have been sick to have it 75 and Sunny
for the sunshine Fest enough about the
weather though the only real problem
with this Festival was the commute
between Sid Splitters Comedy Club in
Tampa and the coastal creative venue in
St Pete these two buildings were home to
99% of the most sought-after shows with
all the biggest names but a quick search
on Google Maps will show these two
venues are nearly 40 minutes away from
each other without traffic I don't know
how many DUIs this caused last weekend
in Florida but asides from that the
distance between the two best venues
made it feel more like an insanely lucky
weekend to be in Tampa with all these
great Comics who happen to be in town
rather than a Comedy Festival that
everyone's a part of together personally
the best part about other comedy
festivals I've attended is the ability
to pop in and out of so many different
shows but at the sunshine Festival if
you want to see a show at sides
Splitters by the time you complete the
journey to the club you've basically
committed to being there all night which
takes away from the festival show
hopping mentality and basically makes it
impossible to just see one person in a
certain lineup at one place then go
catch another show or live podcast at
another Tampa is rapidly growing in
comedy popularity right now besides all
the clubs running down here like Sid
Splitters the gimmick the funny bone
Coastal creative and sunshine City
there's also been two massive comedy
events in Tampa in just the last few
months alone between the sunshine
festival and the carnival of combat
where LS J Gomez defeated Tim butterly
in a boxing match to win the right of
legal adoption it's been about 2 months
since you've been legally adopted by LS
J Gomez what's the worst part about
being his legal son so far
uh it's just you know the uh it's
actually it's a Dream It's you know I
was ready to [__] on this guy and say
like he never picks me up one time he's
he's inattentive he's it's all about his
girlfriend you know but I just he's the
most tender nurturing guy it's crazy and
I had to get punched in the face by him
to find that out yeah overall I would
give the first ever Sunshine Comedy
Festival a strong 8.9 out of 10 this is
definitely an event I will be returning
to every single year it's running and
I'm excited to keep watching it grow
thank you so much to Zach Brian and
everyone else over at sunshine that
helped us out through the entire
Festival thank you to all the comedians
who let us grab these interviews shout
out to all the subscribers who said
what's up and thank you for watching
this video If y'all ain't [__] with
jokeer who are you [__]
with at joke
World let it joke
world and the world is wld
D that's a great uh YouTube channel
World check it out